there are two main ways to practice a
language getting input through listening
and reading and getting output through
speaking and writing
everybody always talks about output
especially speaking but today I want to
discuss the other side of the coin more
specifically I'm going to try to answer
one question is it possible to learn a
language just through input practice
stay tuned till the end because the
answer might surprise you hi I'm Lucas
I'm a Language Coach who speaks 14
languages and on this channel I help
people learn foreign languages faster
more efficiently and in a fun way let's
Dive Right In there are a lot of skills
that go into learning and using a
language but today we'll talk only about
the big four listening reading speaking
and writing as I mentioned a few moments
ago the skills of listening and reading
are called the input skills this is
because they require you to absorb
language rather than produce it like you
do when you speak or write so if you
wanted to could you learn a language
exclusively through practicing input
skills and basically ignoring the output
scales I believe the answer to that
question depends primarily on your
language learning goals take a moment
and think about it what do you dream of
using your target language for are you
looking to read literature in your
target language for example is your goal
to be able to listen to podcasts or
watch movies without subtitles are you
looking to travel and survive
confidently in a place where your target
language is the primary one or do you
want to be a conversationalist able to
talk to anyone about nearly everything
if your goal is ultimately to use your
target language in certain ways then
listening and reading practice might be
enough for you if you have other goals
then listening and writing will not get
you all the way there
if you're skeptical then I have a story
that hopefully will put your doubts to
rest years before I started my own
online language learning school I went
to school in Paris in the hopes of
becoming a conference interpreter if
you're not familiar with conference
interpreting it's a job that requires
you to verbally translate target
language speech into your native
language on the spot as you're listening
to someone's speak it's an incredibly
demanding job which has only made more
challenging by the fact that conference
interpreters are most often employed by
important diplomatic organizations like
the United Nations back then this kind
of language focused job appealed to me
so I attended an event to learn more
about it at some point in the evening I
found myself sitting next to the
director of the interpreting school she
was a French woman who had worked for
many years as a conference interpreter
having to interpret between French or
native language and German her target
language I had been learning German for
a long time at that point so I was eager
to practice German with her and possibly
even impress her with my skills I
decided to start up a conversation with
her all in German when she stopped me
dead in my tracks and she said I'm sorry
but I do not speak a word of German
what cure was a woman who had such good
German listening skills that she could
interpret the language in the world's
most high-stakes diplomatic Arenas and
she couldn't even hold a conversation in
it I was in shock until that moment I
had always assumed that skilled inputers
were always skilled outputters and vice
versa but no when I asked her how such a
thing was possible she told me simply
that as an interpreter all she needed
was a perfect understanding of German
she didn't need to be able to actively
use it so she never developed the skills
to do so I remain curious about this
development even after I went on to
enroll in the interpreting school is it
really possible to have perfect input
scales but zero output skills with each
new student and teacher I met the answer
was the same yes it is it sounds crazy
but it's something a verified time and
time again
so what does this mean for you am I
saying that no matter what your goal is
you will always have to work on
developing all four major language
skills not quite what I'm saying all
boils down to a little known truth about
language learning you will only get the
skills you actively develop you cannot
focus solely on one or two of the major
skills and hope that the others will
magically develop from thin air
there might be some skill transfer here
and there but not enough to make your
proficient at doing something you've
never really practiced so in theory you
could choose to develop only the passive
skills of listening and reading but your
success will depend on how well those
particular skills are aligned with your
goals let's examine this further by
applying it to three different
archetypes of language learner each with
different goals I'll call these
archetypes the reader The Listener and
the speaker first let's talk about the
reader this is a learner who only cares
about understanding written language
like books magazines and newspaper
articles for a person like this solely
practicing input skills is a perfect way
to learn a language in this case you
might not even need to listen just read
as much and as widely as possible and
you will gradually get very proficient
at it and you'll build a massive
vocabulary as well you might not think
Learners like this exist but they're
very common in the area of that
languages languages that have a vast
literary history but are no longer
spoken Latin Greek and Sanskrit are good
examples Learners of these languages can
get by perfectly well without ever
worrying about something like speaking
though even in the case of dead
languages some people try to speak as
well
next The Listener this is a learner who
is primarily concerned with
understanding spoken language this could
be a conference interpreter like I
described earlier or just someone who
really wants to be able to watch YouTube
videos and movies completely in their
target language
just like the reader these people do
perfectly well with a learning routine
focused solely on input skills unlike
the reader however I wouldn't ever
really recommend focusing only on
listening at least not at first if your
long-term language learning goals
involve listening then reading early on
will actually give you an important
boost it will help you identify the
boundaries between Words which will then
become more apparent to you as you build
your learning skills
for this reason I recommend that most
Learners begin their Journeys by
developing a robust listening and
reading practice where they
simultaneously read a beginner text
while listening to Native audio of the
same content only after you've gotten
plenty of this type of practice should
you really try to move on to just
listening otherwise you might just end
up frustrated and give up
finally let's talk about the speaker
this is a learner who wants to
comfortably carry out conversations with
native speakers or to talk at length
about certain topics if you've been
following along then you might already
guess that the speaker faces some
challenges that the listener and the
reader do not the speaker has to
practice both input and output skills
indeed since you need to absorb language
before you can produce it it's not
possible to learn only through outputs
because of that anyone who wishes to
develop good speaking skills will need
to practice at least listening and
speaking and most likely all three of
listening speaking and reading in this
case writing would be the only skill
that is truly optional so for speakers
no I don't think it's possible to learn
only through input or only through
output or rather you need to practice
input and output skills together in a
formula that works something like this
input skills help you gain passive
vocabulary which consists of words and
expressions you can recognize but are
unable to use yourself after building
input skills practicing output skills
will help you gradually turn more and
more of your passive vocabulary into
active vocabulary which naturally are
words you can use reliably in a
conversation this process of taking in
passive vocabulary and then continually
turning it into active vocabulary is
absolutely essential for being able to
speak at all let alone being able to
speak well so if your goal is to speak
you cannot get by with just input or
output scales instead you need to work
with both sets of skills often so that
you can speak comfortably and
confidently in a wide variety of
situations
foreign
so there you go I truly believe it is
possible to learn a language through
listening and reading alone but only if
the skills of listening and reading are
aligned with your long-term language
goals
if your goal is just to understand books
magazines and newspapers then yes it is
possible through lots of reading if your
goal is just to understand movies and
podcasts then yes it is possible through
listening and reading but if your goal
is to speak then no listening and
reading alone will not be enough it
would be a great start but eventually
you'll have to move on to actual
speaking practice if you don't do that
then speaking skills will not just
magically develop out of nowhere so
which of these types of Learners are you
are you a listener a reader a speaker or
something else entirely let me know by
leaving a comment down below and as
always check in the description box for
a super cool article about this very
same topic and more thanks for watching
and as always happy language learning